[موسيقى]
الترحيل الممنهج العربي الجهالين من
المناطق الواسعه من المراعي من طريقه
تربيه الاغنام اللي هي في النهايه حتصل
السوق الفلسطيني والسوق الاسرائيلي ايضا
ليس فقط السوق الفلسطيني ملوثه وتتراكم
داخل
الاجساد البشر
[موسيقى]
الانبعاثات التي تنبعث منها
الجراثيم التي تنمو نتيجه
للتواجد مواد مختلفه في هذه النفايات
الانبعاثات الغازيه ايضا هناك غازات سامه
كثيره تنبعث من نتيجه لتحلل هذه النفايات
عندك غاز الميثان عندك غاز اكسيد
النيتروجين عندك غاز الكبريتيد الهيدروجين
كلها غازات سامه وذات رائحه كريهه
[موسيقى]
نتمنى من المسؤولين اللي في البيئه الناس
اللي هم مثلا
دور في المجتمع دور مع المؤسسات انا بنسلط
الضوء على هذا النقطه لان صحيح في خطر في
المنطقه هذه منها احنا الحلال والاغنام
والاولاد والسكان والاطفال لصحيح جميعنا
في خطر
[موسيقى]
انا قلقه من تدهور صحتي وصحه اولادي وزوجي
وباقي افراد مجتمعي من ان تصبح الاوضاع
سيئه في القريب العاجل نحن بالفعل نشاهد
بعض الاعراض بسبب حرق النفايات الان نعاني
من امراض تتعلق بجهاز التنفسي وهي على شكل
نوبات ولكن نحن ايضا خائفون انه في خلال
سنوات قليله سنرى امراضا مثل السرطان
[موسيقى]